basically we're Downstream of a single
cell from three billion years ago who
was too timid to die and we've inherited
all of its kind of self-consciousnesses
and all of its quirks and foibles but
it's fundamentally just Downstream of
this one cell that couldn't give up I
think there's a lot of that that is
perhaps humorous but most of it's a
tragedy
there's a quote that says life is a
comedy to those who think and a tragedy
to those who feel what do you think that
means
oh I think it's exactly inverted
um there's there's I think there's way
more tragedy when you zoom in at the uh
uh kind of chaos and Nightmare of what's
Happening inside an individual single
cell
um which is kind of how I got interested
in the brain so yeah I think that gets
it exactly wrong who said that right it
was an Errata yeah yeah well the way
that I see it as well is I I would agree
that the people that have greater depth
of insight are the ones that also have a
greater capacity for suffering
yeah I mean like I the way that I see
kind of the modern uh the modern brain
and the modern uh all the other kind of
Legacy issues we have to deal with is
basically we're Downstream of a single
cell from three billion years ago who
was too timid to die and we've inherited
all of its kind of self-consciousnesses
and all of its quarks and foibles and
you know we're dealing with these things
now like for example what medicine all
of medicine and all of science all of
biological science have to deal with but
it's fundamentally just Downstream of
this one cell that couldn't give up
um and and I think I think there's a lot
of that that is perhaps humorous but
most of it's a tragedy
Evolution evolution is a long unbroken
line of most things dying off
so that's a good point and for the most
part as well the
ever the more anxious ever the more
concerned neurotic overthinking version
of that usually being the Adaptive One
yeah well so I've been thinking about
this a little bit uh recently with
respect to
the the way you just described that the
ever anxious overthinking Etc
um I actually believe that there's a
variation in the ways that people
simulate
what happens in their head so basically
if a single event happens something
happens in your world you're at a party
and a conversation goes around and you
you let's say you missed the opportunity
for a well-timed Precision joke that you
know when you simulated in your head
would have would have killed right and
then
some people
will not let that go well think about
that there's a whole phrase in French uh
staircase wit right which is which is
the idea that if you if you kind of
don't say something at a party you'll
figure out the exact right answer the
wittiest response will come to you on
the staircase as you're leaving the
party
which fundamentally I mean that's so so
you could take that as just a kind of
side anecdote or maybe again one of
these cute little aphorisms that that
artists and people throw around but but
what it fundamentally means is something
profound about the brain which is that
we are constantly simulating we are
constantly rehearsing in our mind
um that which
just happened that which is about to
happen in the future and I would guess
that there are some some people those
that are perhaps neurotically inclined
or anxiety inclined those are people
that rehearse and simulate more more and
more and more so whether or not those
people end up being better at being
comedians or you know more likely to to
um kind of throw tragedy onto the world
I don't know but I think it comes from
simulation yes I would be tempted to to
agree and I think there's a an
interesting difference between Daniel
Kahneman and Daniel Gilbert's two views
of Happiness one being based on meaning
almost like a retrospective a happy life
is one which in retrospect you're glad
you lived and the other one Don Gilberts
is the lying on a Lilo with a cocktail
in your hands 23 hours a day for the
remainder of time and I've come to
believe that both of those things you
hear people talk about well I want to be
the more hedonic side I want to be the
more meaningful side and my belief at
the moment is that that is very much
just a a spectrum of temperament if
you're the sort of person who spends a
lot more time being introspective and
ruminative then by Design you're going
to want to do things now which are
almost an investment for your future
self to look back on and bask in their
meaningful glow whereas if you're a
person that's a little bit more in the
moment then you're going to lean more
hedonically and I think that maybe we've
got something similar going on here the
staircase wit for some people may not
even be a thing someone may not even
consider the conversation that they had
earlier on as they're going down the
stairs because they're embraced in
whatever is coming next maybe it's the
stairs maybe it's the party they're
going to later on or the dinner that
they're going to have or whatever
that's a good that's a very good point
that staircase wit is someone living in
the past in some sense right they're
rehearsing the past but the interesting
thing is that it actually counts as
learning for future Behavior so for
example it might not be the case that
they end up in exactly the same scenario
but should they should a conversation at
some future party kind of tend toward
that same punch line perhaps they can in
fact use it in the future
um but but I do think you're right that
sometimes there's this kind of
misalignment with
um the temporal priority that someone
has whether or not they live mostly in
the past present or future I I do not
live in the present I live mostly in the
kind of rehearsed planned future that I
just kind of try to guide towards as if
I'm steering a a dinghy out lost in the
kind of open ocean but there are people
that purely live in the present and I
completely and utterly discount it
um to to an earlier thing if I could if
I can tangent off an earlier thing you
said
um you know so in this in this book I
kind of offer up a lot of different
definitions and kind of uh modern models
and theories of what Consciousness is
but I did not include all of them and I
actually did not include my favorite
definition because this book isn't about
me uh but I so my PhD work I studied
um a parasite a single cell parasite
that gets into mice brains gets into
rodent brains and makes them not afraid
of cats anymore it makes some percentage
of them not afraid of cats anymore the
idea is that it completes the life cycle
it's one of these weird mind control
parasite things that Evolution figured
out where the parasite has to reproduce
inside of a cat inside of a gut of a cat
so in order to get from one to another
it kind of uses the Mouse as a little
intermediate host like like an Uber like
an Uber to the next cat right but along
the way it does like very fancy
neurobiology and mind control that we do
not even remotely understand how that
works but
one thing I realized is after years and
years of basically like learning the
behavior of a mouse and then giving them
this parasite and then watching their
preferences shift so like before you
give the parasite some percentage of
them I mean they're all afraid of the
cat and then after you give them the
parasite it's in their brain it's
mucking around with something and some
percentage of them appear to approach
the cat or at the very least don't seem
to run away as quickly and I was
thinking like you know of course we
scientists study this because we're
trying to extrapolate up to human
behavior and it's like I don't I I I
don't actually know something that you
could not describe as a preference like
that and I and one of my favorite
definitions of kind of identity of who
we are is we're just an accumulation of
preferences
uh that Mouse kind of is shaped from
being afraid of a cat toward liking a
cat we as humans as individuals vary in
our preference for past thinking or
present thinking or future planning and
that kind of thing and the real the real
tragedy to me
um uh is that we don't we don't get like
a little dossier when we meet a person
about what their priorities are and what
their preferences are I mean that's some
of the beauty of interacting and social
life and everything but I would love to
know if a
potential romantic partner and I see the
time Epoch of our preferred choosing
similarly such that when I buy a gift
for her or she gets one for me it's like
aligned temporally not just with all the
other things right like gift giving is
hard and it's mostly because we don't
have access to people's true preferences
or priorities
does that not go back to
the single cell organism or the very
simple types of organism where the
number of inputs would have been super
super low like the fact that you have
pretty much everything is preferences
and pretty much everything has an
opportunity cost by doing a thing you
can't do another thing therefore there
is uh pressure on the decision that you
need to make I seem to remember about
one of the super simple uh creatures
that can spin one way and it means it
goes forward or it can spin another way
and it means that it turns so it can
turn around and round it might be
something that lives in your gut maybe
now but previously would have been
perhaps part of a lineage uh but yeah it
can either if it goes towards a
particular direction and there's more
glucose than there was previously then
it continues to spin in that direction
and then if it's less then it'll
continue to turn until it finds it and
then it'll turn and turn and turn oh
there we go and it'll go forward like
that's just preferences right it has a
preference to be in a environment that
has more glucose and it has two options
the difference is we have a multiplicity
of preferences sometimes many of which
conflict with each other we have a
multiplicity of options but it's
basically the same thing yeah one of the
interesting overlaps between both the
way that uh kind of biologists and
neuroscientists model some organismal
behavior and an overlap with the AI
world and the terms of Art and
artificial intelligence is this idea of
gradient descent that's what it's called
that's the official term gradient
descent but it's exactly what you're
just describing which is for any given
resource there'll be more of it
somewhere it'll be it'll be diffusely
spread around an environment or maybe
the air
and you can actually get extraordinarily
complex behavior from just following
that one simple rule of if more here go
towards if less go away from for example
um we've all had the experience of like
a fly that we SWOT away and then it
immediately circles back and comes right
back to where we are over and over and
over in some like kind of purgatorial
Hell of of this creature like really it
feels personal right it feels like it's
about you and it's never ending and
like
it's because they're following a
gradient descent model of diffusion of
olfactory chemicals that they're
detecting right like they're not doing
anything that is it's not about you it's
about you as a source of molecules that
are diffusing in the air kind of the
farther away you are anyone who wears
perfume knows there's kind of a drop off
right like a one over r squared drop off
of the the wake of the perfume that's
all these things are doing and so you
can get it's really remarkable how how
complex
of a kind of behavior you can get from
like these extremely simple rules and
yeah I mean you know whatever that
single cell was doing three billion
years ago and whatever we're doing now
we're all using the same molecular parts
right like it's it's bizarre people talk
about an individual neurotransmitter is
a one thing dopamine is a reward or or
pleasure it's like well you know
cockroaches use octopamine which is a
very very similar thing to uh uh control
their muscles on their periphery right
like they basically use dopamine or a
very close relative the exact same
chemical
to do something entirely different that
is useful for their needs and so
you know we we think about kind of this
very special and exquisite balance of a
human brain being uh some
some percentage this part right now this
part neurotransmitter that part
neurotransmitter but these things are
like kind of evolutionary Lego bricks
that we've used for three billion years
that are like so out of their original
contexts that they're um
I mean that they're that they interact
in ways that we can't even remotely
predict look at the side effects on any
go to CVS Walgreens I don't know if
you're in Britain I don't know what do
you guys I'm in Austin now so this is
just down the street yeah Okay CBS go to
go to a drugstore or a pharmacy and just
look like if you if you
if you ever wonder why it is the case
that Neuroscience is behind the times if
you ever wonder why we're in like the
Babylonian era and we haven't cured a
single thing and
um uh you know like suicides are on the
rise uh all over the world and we
literally like haven't eradicated like
they did over in the smallpox world or
infectious disease world we haven't we
haven't cured or made understood a
single disease
um just all you need to do is look at
the side effects on any bottle in any
pick or pick a random one as you walk
down the pharmacy and you realize that
there's it's it's input into a
biological system does not give you one
thing it gives you a whole host of a
range of different
um uh consequences so it's not as easy
as like a you know the physicists you
know bless their hearts
um do have it a bit easier where like if
you kind of input something the same
output can come out reliably but in
biology that's that's a non-starter we
don't have that how much do we actually
know about conscious then Consciousness
in your opinion
um I think we're in a
Babylonian era of understanding the
brain and therefore understanding
Consciousness so the way that I kind of
modeled my book is imagining that it was
like 1000 A.D
um and
people you know people spend every night
looking up at the stars right and they
had Exquisite models so again 1000 A.D
um you look up at the stars they move
they're different every night some of
them move one way there's a few that
appear to like Circle back on each other
those are the planets
um but these things are moving and you
know there were there were star like not
in the LA way there were Star Charts
like like real useful star charts that
sailors use to you know navigate at
night across the oceans
um and they were very good at predicting
uh where the stars would be next in the
sky but they had no idea why right they
didn't have the model to explain why but
they could they could say hey look that
star will be at this point in seven days
with decent accuracy
and you know I I kind of see
neurosciences at a similar inflection
point which is we know where in the
brain activity is we know if you show
someone a face there will be activity in
the fusiform face area like ah wow what
a coincidence
um uh it's you know not as if we named
that after the fact or anything but
we don't know why we don't know why it's
there and not anywhere else we don't
know why stimulating with an electorate
that part of the brain creates the
perception or the kind of warping of
faces subjectively to a person whereas
if you activate somewhere else in the
brain it'll create the sound of music or
if you somewhere else it'll create a
visual experience we you know we know
where but we don't know why
so the my the I kind of wrote this book
from that vantage point of if we were
Babylonian era astronomers and someone
was to say you know what are 19 ways of
looking at the sky for example you'd
have 19 different theories most of them
wrong
um but but there are observations in
there and those observations someone
some future scientists some Galileo
hundreds of years later is going to look
back and have to explain all of them
right there's no conscious experience
that a theory should not be able to
explain everything that's happened in
your head yeah that's very interesting
that no matter what your view of
Consciousness right now
the ultimate completed Theory Of
Consciousness needs to be able to
encapsulate all of the experiences that
everybody's had from every single
procedures to maladaptive whatever to
people in comas to lucid dreaming to
sleepwalking
so there is yeah there's no
phenomenological experience that your
brain can create which is invalid
correct in service of the ultimately
correct Theory Of Consciousness that's
interesting yeah and so it's a it's
which with each passing moment I don't
know how to kind of uh uh uh like
quantitatively summate all of the
experiences happening every second round
the world across humans and animals in
every conscious creature but every you
know in terms of what a theory or model
of Consciousness has to explain we are
growing that the amount of data we must
explain is growing exponentially with
every second right orders of magnitude
more every passing second it's getting
harder and harder but you know if
and it's not to say that science will
repeat itself but if you look at the
history of how like electricity and
magnetism and the theory of gravity were
kind of all wrapped into each other you
know it took hundreds and hundreds of
years and the brightest some of the
brightest people that have ever lived in
order to make incremental progress in
some of these things and people had
observations about electricity and
people had observations about magnetism
and people had observations about how
things fall you know at some rate and
there's a bowling ball and there's an
owl and somehow the owl goes the other
way but if you drop the bowling ball it
goes straight down which by the way can
be if you could describe the difference
between a bowling ball and an owl if you
try to drop them from the top of the
tower you've just that's your Nobel
Prize
um but especially if they weigh exactly
the same
um because then they're you know that's
the control condition the mass is the
control condition anyway
um
these these theories over the centuries
were thought to be disparate people
people tried to like bottle electricity
for a while you know they thought they
could like capture it and it would just
like
somehow be contained
um and it took a very long time for
people to realize that these
observations were actually about the
same thing they were actually flip sides
of the same coin that you can make a
one-to-one mapping between electric
electromagnetism and you know an
interesting question is whether or not
in biology we will have a similar kind
of moment whether or not all of these
weird explanations for what it's like in
a brain and our subjective experience
for what we're experiencing on a daily
second by second level all of that will
have to be explained in the kind of
unified theory of gravity of of
Consciousness which
who knows when we'll get there why is it
that Consciousness research is so
difficult
um
I think ultimately
I think ultimately it has to do with
um
data the the
low Fidelity of data collection so
basically the best we have for
subjective experience is language
language is a highly highly compressed
kind of
Sideshow almost
not not even anecdotal
um it's a highly compressed version of
what's happening on the inside of your
head right like imagine a JPEG or like a
perfect image a raw Photon count and
over time you compress it and compress
it to put it on the internet and a phone
and back and forth and until you end up
with something at some point if you
compress too far you end up with
something Indus indecipherable right and
I feel like language is like a extremely
low resolution JPEG of what is
effectively the richest image
a richer image than we've ever uh seen
digitally so like the compression
algorithm that you know you could
probably quantify that somehow in terms
of
you know language is attempting to get
at what's on the inside of your head but
it has evolved I think it is
um subject to the same pressures as you
might say natural selection is
um and so language has survived because
of its utility not necessarily because
of its accuracy
it gets it gets by it does a good enough
job that we can do things like society
and have arguments and complement each
other you know like it's done a good
enough job in the same way that natural
selection and evolution by natural
selection it's not about optimization
it's about doing a good enough job we
have all kinds of horrific
inefficiencies
um and similarly with language I think
you know
you try but like you you know try asking
someone why
they do something and just sit and
listen and be you know entertain
yourself with the answers uh it's almost
certainly the case that those the answer
that you get back is not going to be the
full and complete picture and and is UN
inaccessible to you what is missing so
so for example
um so this my book actually what a
lovely segue
um uh it's the same story told over and
over
it's it's it's one thing told 19
different ways so it's called 19 ways of
looking at Consciousness specifically
because it's one moment told 19
different 19 different explanations as
if you believed in that modern Theory Of
Consciousness and the moment has exactly
to do with your question
which is
uh there is a teenage girl she had
epilepsy and uh when you have epilepsy
they'll try to give you a bunch of drugs
they'll try to treat it they'll try to
find the source of it but sometimes the
epilepsy is a bit mysterious and they
don't know exactly where it is in the
brain and so the surgeon will have to go
in and they'll drill a bunch of holes
they'll drill about like 12 to 20 holes
in the brain they'll insert electrodes
and those electrodes
um
will will
basically be almost like seismic
monitoring stations so these electrodes
will when the seizure doesn't end up
happening uh they will be able to tell
the surgeon exactly where it is and so
this this girl who's awake while these
electrodes are implanted in her
um
uh mostly because the brain does not
feel pain so the surgeons are probing
around and stimulating and they have
these electors inside and some of them
can stimulate they can shoot out
electricity and then that stimulates
that part of the brain and she ends up
laughing
and they end up asking her why did you
laugh
and she says because you guys are just
so funny standing around
and then they go around they do more
stimulation and recording and they they
poke the exact same spot again and she
laughs and they say why did you laugh
and she said oh because the horse is so
funny the picture of the horse you
showed me is so funny
of course none of these things were
funny they weren't just funnily standing
around the horse was not a funny picture
of a horse it was a very normal picture
of a horse
um
and
so what's interesting there is that she
kind of confabulated there's a specific
term for that confabulated the
explanation of why
so when you confabulate she's making up
a highly plausible But ultimately
incorrect story
but there's such Nuance in that in that
moment because first of all who are we
to deny her answer right just I mean we
know that there's an electrodes they're
sticking out of her head and the surgeon
is pushing a button on a computer with a
very specific stimulation protocol that
is you know poking her supplementary
motor area which is causing neurons in
her brain to Output to the the the kind
of muscles in her throat to fire them
and stereotyped and repeat a pattern
though bounces air around the room which
we call laughter right like that's the
answer that's the actual answer
but like maybe she found the horse funny
you know like like it's this funny thing
where like in order to interrogate this
question we have to deny if in order to
interrogate something you want to
disprove it in science you want to
disprove things you never prove anything
you want to disprove it as as well and
strongly as you can we can't ever
disprove someone's self-report
as far as I know currently we cannot and
so ultimately we end up with this kind
of
highly compressed
jpeg version of the world
um you know how good how good would
these these new self-driving cars or uh
these these Vision model computational
Vision models be if they only had to
train on highly compressed like bitmap
images of the world that's effectively
what we're doing when we study
Consciousness we're getting highly
compressed bitmap images
of the world through someone's language
subject enough to biases subject to
incomplete information their own
knowledge about what happened their own
knowledge about themselves that pry is
coming in the social pressures of the
people they're speaking to and not
wanting to look silly or stupid the
limitations of their language in terms
of breadth the awakeness whether they've
had the right amount of caffeine that
day all the way down although just limit
limit limit limit
whether or not they have a mind control
parasite whether or not they've got
electrodes sticking out to the top of
their head in a room with a funny horse
on the on the wall yeah well I mean it's
it's interesting that you've got this
situation where
something happens which is
arguably involuntary as in not self I
don't really know what involuntary would
mean in the the version of reality we're
talking about here but it wasn't
self-generated in terms of the first
mover of that particular stimulus
and then the has retrospectively been a
story told
by the girl about why she did the thing
and there's other
situations like this as well I think
where when you show is it people that
have maybe had what's this center of the
brain called when they open that up
corpus callosum yeah when people have
had the Corpus callosums removed so that
the brain is genuinely in two separate
halves yeah they can do things where
they show one half of the brain an image
of something and then the other hand
goes and picks out of a pot and if they
show them a nut a lot of the time
they'll pick a nut out but then when
they say why did you pick the nut it's
like I'm a massive fan of nuts or
yesterday my mum was talking about nuts
or earlier on today I saw a billboard
that was showing an image of a nut or
whatever it might be
um
what do you think is going on there and
and is that anything indicative about
Consciousness or it's usefulness or its
reason for being here that there is this
narrative
sense to things there's this sort of
desire to be explanatory
yeah I mean I think those those split
brand procedures which I think are still
done but only in extraordinary cases
maybe like one a year now or One A
decade
um
it's I mean think about
it's the profound implication of the
fact that okay let's let's take a
physical feature let's take a mountain
and cut it in half now you have two
halves of a mountain
let's take like a cake and cut it in
half now you have two halves of a cake
that are completely you know there's
nothing different about them nothing
emerged or nothing nothing de-emerged I
don't know what the word right word
would be like when you cut it in half if
you cut the Earth in half the whole
chapter in this is why is it
um why is there a difference between if
you cut the Earth in half
versus if you cut a brain in half in the
earth case you'd get like geotechronic
forces in the world would spin out of
control and basically all all life would
die as we know it as like the ozone got
stripped and gravity got all wonky
um but if you cut a brain in half
you just get you resolve to two
independent thinking things right
utterly remarkable because it means it
means a few things just like from first
principles it means that we have more
neurons than we need to be basically
conscious right
which means all of this stuff about oh
animals are and are conscious because
they have so many fewer neurons than us
it proves as a sufficiency condition
that you do not need
um you know a human amount of neurons in
order to be conscious and not even
conscious like a human right you could
have half and you can still be mostly
kind of
um nobody can really figure out what the
difference is there's in in the
neurology kind of the history of
Neurology there's all these cases of
people having
large Brain disorders or traumas and
themselves not even necessarily noticing
but also the doctors and people in the
room and their friends and partners not
even noticing something is wrong
we're not even noticing that that
they're different right and so there so
the new ways of thinking about that one
it's saying wow what a remarkable piece
of uh a Machinery or biological kind of
Goo the brain is like the fact that it
can be so malleable you can you can kind
of live without half a brain and you can
still be a functional human you can
still think and and love and write
poetry and speak and all these things
I see tragedy in those in that in those
moments because what it means to me is
that
we have such a deficient set of tools to
access what's going on in someone else's
mind
it should be the case that if someone
has their mind split into two
hemispheres
um
we should be able to know right away
like you know imagine some sort of like
futuristic device that just goes up and
says oh yeah well your cognition has
changed in exactly this way you are now
this different here's what we predict
would would be different
um
as it is we kind of like literally our
language is such a poor proxy for what's
going on on the inside of a head that
doctors sometimes don't even notice well
if it's if it's not something that's
noticed by the person the brain owner
then right
presumably the
for all of the wondrous stuff that's
going on inside of the brain uh
mechanically the phenomenological
experience of having a brain and of
being conscious is really all that's
happening it's how does this cash out in
terms of the experience of the
experience habit and if that person is
able to continue through life with the
Charles Whitman
brain tumor or with the the
um Railway sleeper sticking up through
the top of the head and it happened to
not notice or whatever if it doesn't
change functionally or
phenomenologically how it feels to be
that person
I do uh what would that matter like
surely the the end result of
Consciousness is the experience of
Consciousness itself that that is the
end Cash Out result of it I I don't know
if there is anything more than that so
yeah maybe the the
alien could come around and say well
actually you seem to be missing a little
bit of your hippocampus or whatever it
might be right right but if to that
person that experience hasn't changed
would that even matter
right so that that then would give
um validity and priority to
the subjective report right to be like
okay well that is what matters the most
which is the difficulty because we want
to be we want to do that
but it seems also to be clearly the case
that whatever's going on underneath
there's a lot of different ways to
create consciousness
you can you can miss a few you can have
a few neurons die you can get a
concussion you know hypothetically
you're a different person you should be
a different person if you have a few
neurons die out on you right
hypothetically something is different
that you know it's like the old ship of
Theseus the Planks on the ship do you
know this identity like you take a ship
and it crosses the ocean and you replace
one plank at a time is it the same ship
at the end of the day even though none
of the planks of wood are the same you
could do the same you can imagine a
hypothetically similar case for for
neurons
um so again one of the chapters in the
book
um is actually a kind of direct verbatim
interview between myself uh Christopher
a prominent neuroscientist and a friend
of mine a colleague of mine Jonathan who
uh ended up passing away from a
glioblastoma tumor so he had a
glioblastoma and a cerebellum
um and he was a MD PhD so I did my PhD
at Stanford he was an MD PhD at Stanford
and in neuroscience and a radiologist
and was working at I think doing his
residency and radiology at Harvard when
he passed away from this tumor but
before he passed away
um he got a surgery to try to try their
best to kind of carve out as much of the
tumor as they could and they removed
about 20 billion neurons
20 billion so we have about 80 let's say
we have 80. uh total that's the the new
estimate as of 2022 86 billion
um
about a quarter of his brain by count
right 20 billion so imagine this with a
ship at Theseus you know one plank at a
time thing you've just taken out a
fourth of the ship
and he
doesn't really notice a difference he
wakes up you know he's like yeah some
things are different like it's harder
for him to walk in a straight line it's
harder for him to play piano uh which he
used to do as a kid
um
but mostly he's like I can't tell
everything he I think an exact quote is
he said every the me part of me is still
there like everything is still there
and what that what what are we supposed
to do with this information as a
neuroscientist right like this is the
the Crux of the reason I included in the
in the book is because it's it's
it's equal parts maddening and
fascinating which is like how the hell
is it the case that you could take it if
you take any computer chip if I ripped a
quarter of my iPhone off it doesn't work
anymore right you could there's not even
a quarter of it that I could rip off
that would not fundamentally alter it
um but for some reason the brain has
this
either either it's doing so much more
than we realize and the conscious part
is just such a small kind of
screen that gets displayed that like you
can take out so much of it and you know
very little of it actually gets kind of
uploaded to the the screen part of
things or the screen just does its best
with what it has and it just takes that
as the whole thing no matter what it
gets no matter what kind of gets pushed
into it no matter what input no matter
if you're a cricket or a frog or a cat
or a human or a human who's missing a
quarter of their brain it gets pushed in
and you have a conscious experience and
it does its best and that's all you get
and you from the inside will never know
and I think that's probably where we're
at it's fascinating to think what the
difference is between a brain and an
iPhone and it seems to me that the
iPhone has
individual discrete components that are
individually completely relied upon in
order for any part of the whole to be
able to work if you break the battery
then there is no power if you break the
screen then there is no image if you
break the processor then there's no
processing if you break the antennae
there is no signal so on and so forth
but it seems like I don't know like
Consciousness in the brain is maybe
distributed a little bit more
decentralized in some way that if you
get rid of a part of it that maybe bits
can compensate or maybe they didn't need
to compensate because it's sufficiently
distributed that Consciousness is
everywhere in the brain or maybe we're
not a brain at all maybe we're an
antennae that is receiving broadcast
signals from something else the I think
that you talk about that as well that's
a quite a popular theory that it might
not be self-generated from within the
brain at all it might be receiving
Consciousness somehow from The Ether I
don't know
yeah so so there are ways where it's
similar and there are ways where it's
different right so it's diffuse uh it's
diffused in the sense that if you if you
are young if you are a kid and you get
an injury or if you're born with some
part of your brain missing the brain
will do its damnedest to try to kind of
like co-opt other parts of the brain to
serve that function so a kid born
um with you know with maybe has a stroke
a neonatal stroke or something like that
that whatever whatever function was
supposed to be there will kind of get re
integrated into other parts but but
similar to the iPhone if you have a
stroke in your visual cortex as an adult
you're done like you don't see if you
have a stroke in the language area
you're done you don't you don't do
certain parts of language you might be
able to there's some totally bizarre
ones where like some people can still
sing even though they can't speak or
they can you know there's some weird
kind of Oliver sexy and kind of
anomalies but in general
it it is true that like this functional
specialization which in the adult which
is more like the kind of
set and printed iPhone where it's like
if you break anything you might not you
might not be able to make it back
um it's just not true in the beginning
and and and it's it's so remarkable how
malleable Things Are
um in the in the kind of early
pre-critical period brain yeah the the
the
so each each of these chapters
um right so I'm telling this story of
this teenage girl who by the way when
she laughs also experiences the
subjective feeling of joy and mirth
which is part of also this interesting
kind of the hard problem of
Consciousness I believe that like you
know these physicists are over there
like thousands of them under like LHC
and CERN being like oh we're going to
study one particle because within this
particle is the origin and secrets of
all the universe if we just split it up
into in the right ways or if we
carefully watch which with the right
theories I kind of think this this
girl's story has the same uh multitudes
contained within it like if you want you
can unpack it into a lot of different
really interesting things about the
brain but so one of them
um and so but in some sense of course I
can't I can't simultaneously believe all
of these 19 things
um so I'm kind of ghost writing each of
the chapters from I kind of put on my
journalist hat and and was like okay if
I'm a journalist writing a piece about
this Theory how would I tell this story
it's not necessarily mine so one one
thing I try to do is try to make my best
case for that antenna the end I'm using
quotes if you're anyone's listening on
the radio uh they're air quotes
um uh the the kind of antenna theory of
consciousness which is which which I
which was so funny because so I got
invited to a to kind of witness as a
journalist
um a debate that was happening in India
with the Dalai Lama and at their kind of
um Outcast Monastery that India had
given them because they were kicked out
of Tibet and the Dalai Lama did this
thing where I guess he does this every
year he invites scientists from the west
and scientists from the East to to
debate about the origins of the universe
like what is morality what is you know
he'll invite physicists and biologists
and mathematicians and they'll have like
a East first West you know yin yang kind
of debate and I get there and the first
night
um
the kind of team West and this is a
friendly debate right but team West is
sitting around a table and there's two
questions that are dominating everyone
as we you know we've just flown across
the world and arrived at this at this
Monastery in the middle of like India's
Oklahoma and um uh
the questions were is there wi-fi
and are we allowed to kill the flaw the
mosquitoes in front of the monks
and what I thought was so funny about
that
um was this idea that actually According
to some theories of how the brain works
those two questions are the same
question or rather they're the same
moral question so think about what Wi-Fi
is like Wi-Fi is you have a chip inside
your computer inside your router and
it is
um basically like specifically designed
to collect a very specific
kind of energy again not in the away
real real talk
um sorry I live in LA so I have to
constantly be uh uh making caveats to
when I say things like piezoelectric
crystals and energy and Consciousness I
mean it in in my way
um
so
you I mean we have these chips which are
specially designed to pick up a very
very thin frequency band in the
electromagnetic spectrum that is Wi-Fi
you can hit you have it for all kinds of
things right you have different
different chips that can pick up
different pieces of the invisible world
that is permeating around us
um and there's a very interesting Theory
Of Consciousness which is it's it's it's
it tends to be Eastern
um or you know it's it
it's related to pan psychism in the
sense that the idea is that
Consciousness permeates the world
permeates the universe it's all around
us it's in our subatomic particles it's
everywhere in the same way gravity is
infused and all these fundamental forces
of nature are infused in particles
around us and the world around us and
the universe around us and that maybe
what Consciousness is what a brain is is
just kind of a little like Wi-Fi chip
but for the Consciousness right it's
like a physical structured
piece of reality you organize matter in
a certain way and once you do that it
can pick up a very narrow band of the
electromagnetic spectrum of things
floating around us right and so I just
thought it was really hilarious that the
two the answer was no we were not
allowed to kill the Flies the mosquitoes
but what's funny is nobody cares if you
like smash a router right
but like I don't see them as any
different I see the Mesquite like you
know the mosquitoes running around like
an immune cell to me like I don't think
it's conscious I don't I don't I don't
know but some people there do right like
like very prominent neuroscientists and
you know I just disagree with them and
that though is again if it's a thousand
A.D I don't know if I'm right I could be
one of the astronomers looking up at the
sky just totally wrong right like but
we're all like kind of pitting our
theories against each other in the way
but we're still all pre-cabernacus
pre-galileo we don't even have a
telescope yet is the problem what do you
think it's like for animals that can go
to sleep with one half of their brain at
a time I'm pretty sure
flamingos can do this
I think you're confusing do they stand
on their uh one leg they stand on their
leg is that the same thing I don't know
I don't know someone I know someone is
going to correct us don't worry the
internet will correct us on this but so
so many migrating birds can do it
because they have to sometimes sleep
while they're still in the air they
don't they don't land for a while I
don't know if flamingos migrate I don't
know enough about them okay but what do
you think it's like what do you think
the experience of having half of your
brain asleep is like I have experienced
this I have chronic insomnia and I feel
like sometimes when I walk around the
world like a zombie that I'm half asleep
when I when I so what I find very
interesting that even
um
so
okay so an interesting tangent would be
why why is it different or is it
different than what we were talking
about earlier of the splitting the brain
down the down the line right like like
is it actually very similar to those
split brain patients in terms of
phenomenology in terms of what they're
experiencing in which case you know it
doesn't really feel like anything it
just kind of feels like
you're
ah
I I can't explain I'm using stupid jpeg
compression to try to explain this whole
thing is jpeg compression of of thoughts
right
um
so
so one thing though that any Theory Of
Consciousness should have to explain is
like the few moments as you wake up from
sleep
which are sometimes confusing and
jarring I the way that I think about it
is kind of like
um my brain is like a town and during
sleep it like all the electricity goes
out even though that's a terrible
analogy but just imagine it like
Consciousness you know the electricity
goes out but that it's slowly powered up
like one house at a time in one
neighborhood at a time and it takes me
like four hours to basically like Turn
The Lights On Again
but the question which I think is
analogous or maybe
um uh similar to yours is kind of like
how is it the case
that a brain can just do that can like
slowly wake up like one neighborhood at
a time one brain region at a time
you know I feel it kind of like I'm less
there I feel like a little bit less
capable of maybe some kinds of thought
or thinking
but I'm still conscious the entire time
as each of my little houses and
neighborhoods power themselves back up
and so I imagine like if you're one of
these whales I know whales can
definitely sleep with with one
hemisphere
um a certain migratory Birds I think the
sea lion
um or it might be the sea lion or the
sea auditor otter some mammal that goes
back and forth between land and water
when when they sleep on land they sleep
in both hemispheres and when they sleep
in the water they use only one which I
think is a totally unexplained bizarre
someone should figure that out
um but so
I don't know it's probably like all of
these uh neurological case reports were
reporting where the person just doesn't
know the difference
you know we have a lot of variation
throughout the day we can be hungry we
can be tired we can be under caffeinated
we can be over caffeinated we can be
cranky all of these things are totally
different
subjective States and they are
it's very normal for us to describe them
in terms of underlying metabolism or
biology for example people get cranky
when they're hungry this is a thing it's
a common phenomenon
um what that means is like that means
that Consciousness is so fragile
and our sense of self and our sense of
priority and preferences and is so
fragile that something so silly can
completely change what we pay attention
to so now we're going to start to pay
attention to food uh signals and signs
in the world we're gonna like our sense
of smell we'll coordinate and uh
rearrange to be about food
um you know like we desire these things
and our entire perceptual apparatus kind
of shifts to make it more likely to
extract that thing from the world we
desire that means that Consciousness is
this like really Dynamic and really
fragile thing
um
and you know people people there's this
whole Trend these days to talk about
like uh psychedelics and what they do
and how they're the window into the seat
of the soul and they're going to change
everything and but it's like I I don't
understand why I actually just
being tired
isn't just as subject as interesting of
the question about the phenomenology of
Consciousness as you know seeing skulls
in the ivy because you you took too many
mushrooms like it's the same like things
are being perturbed and they're being
perturbed in a matter of degree not kind
and so like I think there's Clues
everywhere
um we just have to kind of catalog them
I agree I think one of the reasons that
people are more interested in the
mushrooms is that it's significantly
more enjoyable than permanently being
tired which I imagine if you've ever
taken mushrooms it sounds like you're
tired quite a bit so you'll probably be
able to compare the two but yeah this
I I always think about this to do with
the show because this you'll be episode
550 something on this podcast
congratulations thank you uh very
illustrious uh a few years and um
what I get to do every single time that
I sit down and have a conversation with
someone
is I get to stress test the capacity of
my verbal
agility right now there's other ways
other types of knowing other ways that I
might be yesterday played a fantastic
game of pickleball can't really tell you
why but on other days I play a bad game
of pickleball is that still IQ well yeah
it's also body blah blah blah anyway as
far as I can see it doing the podcast is
as close to a uh health check fitness
test type scenario for where's my brain
at at the moment uh how did I sleep how
hydrated am I what was my nutrition like
all of the contributing factors how
stressed how blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah all that stuff and
observing that really really closely
over the last five years of doing this
has been super fascinating to me seeing
just what can change the different
capacities uh can I increase the engine
size can I press down harder on the
accelerator like can I apply more
cognitive effort in order to be better
if I apply too much effort does that
make me worse are there things that I
can do in terms of skills that I can
acquire that can actually raise the
ceiling if the maximum of where I can
get to uh are there things I can do
acutely to be able to give me boosts uh
over the short term
caffeine dosage and sleep all that stuff
and that has been a really enjoyable and
insightful experience just going through
the varying mental States of what
happens if I do this what happens if I
do that how does my verbal agility my
dexterity my recall my vocabulary all of
that stuff change based on what I do if
I warm up before if I speak to my
housemate for 30 minutes before I begin
what does that do why is there this sort
of momentum thing that seems to happen
when I'm speaking that you actually seem
to get better over time and when does
that start to drop off and is that
because of fatigue is that because of
bored and what happens if you change the
subject all of these different things
not exclusively due to Consciousness
because your saying words hopefully that
represents something cogent about a
topic so you actually need to have it
some degree of expertise or insight
about whatever it is you're talking
about but then there's a base layer
below that of
like the nuts and bolts of having a
conversation and of being there and of
talking in a manner that is like
well-timed and resonates with brevity
and precision and stuff that's been
really interesting that's been my little
laboratory that I've been playing about
it and did you do the the Preparatory
speaking with something so what's funny
is I haven't spoken to someone
um like like used words in 24 hours or
so definitely not this morning right I
live I'm a bachelor alone in my little
La apartment and um
I actually thought to myself oh shoot I
have an interview today I had I
literally haven't spoken at all so what
I did was actually
um I have to give a talk tomorrow and I
recorded my talk over and over not
because I needed to but it actually just
to get in kind of the Cadence and rhythm
of speech and speaking and I have no
idea why is that the equivalent of
stretching you know is that the
equivalent of before a match like I
don't I don't really understand why but
I've I have found similarly that if I
um don't speak for a while I just lose
the ability so quickly yes like so
remarkably quickly that it actually
bothers it kind of bothers me my uh
Speech addiction coach miles will be
able to give us an answer I'm sure he's
got me doing a vocal warm-up that my
housemate is very familiar with as I go
through different tongue twisters and
stuff like that so there is something
functional that you're doing to the the
physiology of the voice box of the
tongue the tongue unbelievably complex
little bit of kit that you need to
actually genuinely get going there is
kind of a a warm-up procedure but
there's something else as well I noticed
this over the weekend I went to one of
the strangest Bachelor parties I've ever
been to in my entire life this weekend
we went to Houston and the we ate
only Asian food for an entire weekend
nobody went out there was no nightclubs
no nothing else we observed Shabbat
on the Friday night we went to an Asian
spa and a bunch of the guys got
Asian scrub completely naked Asian
scrubs and then on the Saturday night we
did a Jeffersonian dinner uh with 26
dudes
a non-typical bachelor party to say the
least but what I noticed because there
was less debauchery than I might be used
to at these events I was talking an
awful lot and after you get into a
rhythm after a while your brain is just
firing on all cylinders
what's going on there
yeah what what if you told me if you
told me to run if you told me to run for
three hours I wouldn't I wouldn't want
to continue running I would I would be
dead
if you tell me to speak for three hours
hour four I'm like Bring it on I got
this i got this in the tank and
everything's firing and all of the ideas
are big and oh very strange
yeah so it it immediately makes me think
I wonder what would happen with those
these language robots the language
models that are now all popular right uh
gbt and and and Google's one where
they're able to produce text like
you know to all this debated question
about whether or not they're
like us at all
if so they would also have to have that
effect right like like what if one of
these language robots we encourage it to
speak so so much that it just gets into
this manic high and just never shuts up
oh you can program in boredom as well
you could yes uh to get to get your
hitchhikers the Marvin robot um so
I think about this um a little bit right
I mean every every physical
sport at high performance has warm-up
and we maybe simply believe that it has
something to do with uh the you know
limberness or stretching or getting the
the physiology prepared but the brain is
also a physiology machine right I mean
it is also responsive to the physiology
and the state of the of the um
of the body so what I wonder it would be
like
foreign so
so
okay one thing that I find really
fascinating with with language and
conversation and it and it's kind of one
of these key Windows into how the brain
actually works under the hood
is you can end a sentence
with something very surprising so if
like I don't you know I'm as I'm
speaking right now you in your brain you
are coming up with a probabilistic model
for the likelihood of how I'm going to
end up finishing the sentence I was
probably going to finish that sentence
with the word sentence right uh look I
did it again
um and
if I were to finish it with unicorn or
like some other word that was completely
and utterly surprising which if I if my
brain were firing in a more cylinders I
would probably do as a live example but
I can't right now even though I have no
idea which words I'm choosing it feels
really hard for me to actually go like
completely orthogonally and to pick a
random word out of the dictionary
the very fact that we can actually
detect traces so if we had an EEG on
your head as you listen to me speak and
you as soon as you got to that
surprising word a couple hundred
milliseconds afterwards your brain would
register an error
and I don't know if there's work done on
whether or not
if you warm up you're more likely to
register that error but my guess is
actually that
in order to generate speech
you have to listen to yourself speak
and you're having to predict and
basically play the game of
how to finish a sentence so as to not be
surprising
and that is both a listening task and a
generating task so when you're
generating speech you're also listening
and you're having to cancel out the
exact kind of speech patterns that you
make in a very odd and interesting way
um you know your voice sounds different
to you be partly because when you hear
it recorded versus what it's like on the
inside of your head yeah there's some
bone conduction through the jaw and all
the physical stuff but it's also the
case that everything every single thing
you say because it's a motor Act your
brain is also canceling out the
consequences of that motor act as it
sends it to the sensory parts of the
brain so it's it sounds different in
part because when you hear your own
voice you're not getting that copy
anymore a copy that your brain is
sending so your brain it's kind of like
a carbon copy on a check right like when
your brain is engaging in a motor output
it'll send one copy to the muscles and
another copy to the sensory parts of
your brain being like hey look I'm about
to move in this One Direction don't be
surprised when I do this is the whole
reason the world looks stable when we
move our head around and dash our eyes
back and forth three times a second the
only way that works is because your
brain knows exactly where that movement
is about to be it's constantly living in
the in like a few hundred milliseconds
in the future
and so I would guess
that the reason talking before doing
these interviews helps is you're you're
not just preparing the muscles you're
preparing the whole apparatus of
prediction and surprise and like kind of
word completion
and you know these these language robots
that people think are sentient or
similar to human speech they're
they're just long if statements and they
do not have surprise in that way they
have you know there's you could probably
build in statistical surprise but
they're kind of doing to fill in they're
kind of like elaborate Mad Libs version
uh versions of of language which doesn't
have
the context and capacity that the human
brain does to understand the surprise
and that's something that you know we're
going to need AGI to get there we're
gonna it's so much harder to make so for
example
it's easy to make a language robot well
now it is
um
it is I I challenge anyone in that field
to make a robot that feels staircase
with
right that leaves the party still
simulating what it could have or should
have said and when it comes up with what
it believes to be the cleverest one
feels bad
right if when a language robot does that
I will I will officially vote sentient
but until then like these are just if
statements I like that as the Judgment
of whether or not we've reached AGI
sentience all right what yeah what about
the pinball machine analogy what's that
yeah
um yeah yeah you can make that the uh
modified Turing test uh Patrick
Patrick's modified Turing test the robot
doesn't have to convince you uh that
it's a linguistic you know of its
linguistic ability it has to feel bad
that it the conversation went poorly
um
yeah so another
um another one of the chapters thank you
um is so
so there's this and there's this analogy
that I heard which a lot uh many many
neuroscientists in the field and some
colleagues share which is a very good
one which is that that when people try
to understand why the human brain in its
modern form and its current form has
some quirks
um one of the best ways to think about
it is to think about it like a power
station so imagine imagine you're trying
to make uh you know you have a water
wheel in the 1700s I don't know when it
happened
um
and so you have this this power
generation electricity being generated
by the movement of water and then you go
through all of the technological step
changes you have steam engine and then
you start to burn coal then suddenly you
have nuclear and then you have solar
power and suddenly you have some sort of
like AI natural gas hybrid grid you know
like our energy pipelines and our our
kind of power stations have evolved with
new technologies but imagine the human
brain is the equivalent of effectively
like starting with a power station and
then never being able to turn it off
as you had to evolve and add on all of
these other kinds and ways of generating
power so if you can imagine like an old
water wheel that we then threw a solar
panel on and tried to connect with like
pneumatic tubes and and made it a steam
engine for a while and had to make a
furnace to shovel coal into it uh
ultimately had to stick like a nuclear
reactor on top of it or nearby and these
things are all still together because
you can never ever ever turn it off
you had to keep the energy running you
had to keep the town powered
that's that's what we are that's what a
mammalian brain is it's this like you
know we've never been able to turn off
from that single cell three billion
years ago
that was the original Power Station and
three billion years later we're still
running
and so that's the kind of uh analogy du
jour in Neuroscience that's the the
common one and I was thinking about it
and
um I think it's a very good analogy for
a physicist it's a very good analogy
from a physicist to understand the kind
of biomechanics of how brain works but
it's missing something crucial which is
that
um
at some point we became subject we
subjectivity came on came online
and and so I I was trying to think like
okay if I were to tell the story again
what would I how would I retell it and I
actually think that the evolution of the
game of pinball
is the most
um most most reflects the metaphorical
mapping into the evolution of the human
brain and the reason is two reasons
um one
I was so fascinated
um I played this
digital virtual pinball like in the mid
90s like Windows 95 it came with some
pinball thing right and so now you have
the entirety of the virtual universe you
can you can create anything you can
software you know the software can
design anything any any kind of thing
you want and yet still they made it have
like tilt
right tilt is a thing that pinball
machines evolved because they were too
expensive and you didn't want people
just like smashing them around the
virtual version does not need tilt you
could completely eliminate that rule set
but there was this Legacy issue of ah
Pinball's been around for a while people
are familiar with tilt
um let's keep it in let's keep it in the
bells and whistles and sights and sounds
of the of the physical world and try to
virtualize it and I went back and looked
at the history of pinball and it turns
out it has like these lovely analogs to
the evolution of kind of bilateria and
biological systems which is like it
started as one thing and then slowly it
became more and more of something that
you could control so it started as
literally you just put a ball at the top
of a incline and then you just hope and
bet on where it ends up you have no
power over it you have no way to exert
any Force and then eventually
um uh it becomes a little bit of a
bigger thing and then people started to
move it around to kind of like force the
Fate that they most wanted
um and then it had to evolve the Tilt
mechanism to prevent that from happening
and then flippers came along and those
flippers meant that you could control
your fate instead of just be like washed
around by the current
um and then it eventually had to combine
this like the physical mechanics of the
pinball machine which with with physical
flippers and a real ball which is
subject to inertia and like Mike the
debris that we can't even see which
changes its route so you can never kind
of Hit the same shot twice
um and then
on top of that it added this like
electronic layer right as pinball
evolved throughout the 20th century it
added this electronic layer of bells and
whistles and and lights and
um and eventually there's this funny
thing where basically pinball
um was about to die out because the
world was becoming more interesting like
Hollywood was uh ascending and pong had
happened and suddenly the the there was
a virtual world that was much more
compelling than this silly game of of
throwing a you know silver sphere
on an incline and leaving it up to
defeat and there's this moment I think I
think the game is called high speed
which
the pinball designers were like you know
what we maybe could do is we could we
could make it not that your your ball is
something separate from you which is
just trying to accumulate points but
what if we made because some narrative
around it such that it seemed as if you
were playing as the ball
and you as the ball had a goal and the
high speed was just a game where you had
to run from some police you know it was
like GTA it was the original GTA Grand
Theft Auto and um this game became a
sensation and it was in part because
suddenly it became a story and it became
storytelling
and there was through nothing nothing
was added except this narrative and
suddenly you weren't playing pinball uh
um you weren't playing pinball as you
you were playing pinball as the ball
and to our earlier question about this
narrative and the and the need for
narrative in the human brain and how
we're all just stories
I found that to be like a really nice
analogy to the kind of biological
evolution of of organisms which is to
say they started out without a story
with no storytelling device and then at
some point they learned to gain control
over their own fate you know hands
Clippers the little cilia that you were
talking about earlier which uses descent
gradient to choose to go one way or the
other that's like the flipper
um and then we had literal flippers and
then we became story and then we had to
combine the physical part with the
electrical part as neurons figured out
how to keep charge on one side of their
membrane and then
we became ver you know maybe one day
we'll become virtual like the Windows 95
version of it so so I actually like
basically I just
I just think pinball tells the the
history of the evolution of a pinball
machine tells the story of biology in a
really interesting way you've continued
to build throughout the evolution of our
brain this unbroken lineage from
whatever that first single-celled
organism was
has continued to add in features and
it's had to
it's had to work out a way to add in
something which is adaptive to the new
environment that this creature finds
itself in or the way that the local
ecology has changed or whatever but it's
difficult to get rid of the existing
thing because all of the changes occur
very slowly if you were to go from
single cell and what it had to human and
what we have you would retain very
little you would change an awful lot but
it's been iterative over time does that
suggest that brains have never lost any
functionality then
hmm
um
yeah that that's interesting so we would
have to be more specific in the way we
framed the question so human brains
because it is certainly the case that
for example I'm just thinking of the
very basic there's some salamander that
lived in a cave and lost its eyes right
it just evolved out and like there was
no light in there and it just didn't
need eyes anymore and so it just slowly
became blind like the whole species is
now blind so that that organism's brain
has significantly changed it lost a
function
um
but
this is a kind of nuanced
I'm about to make a nuanced statement
which I don't even know is which I don't
even know if it's it's completely
accurate
um
and it's pretty broad I and kind of
anthropomorphizes evolution as if it's a
thing I don't think evolution by natural
selection cares whether or not it gains
or loses a function with any passing
iteration
I think a large amount I mean we used to
have a tail
right we don't have tails anymore I
think about this sometimes in terms of
uh I think I think there was some time I
like almost slipped in the shower and I
think as I was catching myself on the
curtain I thought to myself God damn I
wish I had a tail which would have been
really useful then to catch me from
falling as it is for all the monkeys in
all the trees right and then I started
to think about uh this is what I this is
this perhaps why I live alone
um and then I started to think about
like
what is it like
to control a tail what is the experience
of a primate that has a tail sticking
out its back you can't see it right
so like how do you know to use it to
latch around something it feels like
actually a very subconscious or
unconscious thing that they must be
doing they must kind of have some
awareness
of the tail behind them and what it can
and cannot do and the fact that it could
or could not grab certain things if
you're falling or you know if you need
stability or something but then the
question is how does it think about or
control how does a monkey think about or
control its tail consciously if all it
is is this kind of appendage in our
behind us that you never really get the
visual or proprioceptive feedback for
and I and I
I my conclusion
um
based on nothing was uh that maybe this
is what it's like to be some kinds of
kind of lesser animals on the
evolutionary Spectrum so smaller smaller
animals that might not be mammals like
an octopus or something you know maybe
it's maybe it's
as if it's it's as dark to them
subjectively on the inside of their head
as it would be
to us as primates being able to control
a tail that we no longer have
so so and and maybe it's just all that
right maybe the whole thing is that
maybe the whole thing is this Darkness
where it feels like they can do some
things they have some motor computation
going on about what they can and cannot
do in their media environment but
fundamentally the whole thing the the
whole
Cinerama is
is darkness is unconscious but so they
would still look as if they're acting
and behaving and going around and moving
around the world but there's kind of
nothing that the lights aren't on on the
inside and so just very simply to the
um like we've lost the ability to
control the tail so that means our
brains aren't functionally kind of
different than they used to be even a
couple hundred thousand or a million
years ago
so so yeah I don't I don't think
Evolution cares whether or not it's a
game we think of gain as good and loss
is bad but evolution doesn't care it
just wants you to just wants you to go
yes and I suppose that we're now in an
environment which is very very quickly
changing to the point where Evolution
amongst humans at the moment is going to
be incredibly difficult to optimize for
in any case you go one generation to
another generation and all of the things
that you optimized for within the last
mutation is now no longer viable
completely pointless you know when the
bicycle I was learning about how the
bicycle got invented and it it um
liberated a lot of women because uh
women were able to go out without a
chaperone which would have been
something that would have been
catastrophic in Victorian Britain uh but
now they had a bicycle and they could
just cycle around and uh you think okay
well now we're going to adapt we're
going to adapt people for bicycle riding
you go well within four generations of
that everybody's got a car
so that's that's not gonna that's not
gonna work
um what about your favorite or the most
exotic
explanation that you looked at for the
book when it comes to Consciousness
which one was the wildest or your
favorite
um
yeah that's a good question
um
I mean I think the wildest Barnum if you
ranked Choice voted across all
neuroscientists is the the uh Penrose
hammeroff uh orcor Theory which is the
the kind of
so
so nobody's come up with a good
explanation right nobody has one so it's
kind of fun that like theories get to
find get get their Heyday they get to
stand up on stage and give their speech
um because we don't really have
disconfirming evidence it's pretty hard
and one of the
the thorny pieces of this is we do not
know
how to describe
we do not know how to describe in
physical terms why the brain is not
determined why it's not the case that
like like like the little pinball at the
top that it gets pushed and it just ends
up there and it will always end up there
because that's fate and that's physics
determinism would say your brain is also
just you know tens of trillions of tiny
little pinballs that are called protons
bouncing around and no matter what you
do you're going to end up in the same
place you started we still don't know
how to get around that so you get to do
all kinds of wacky things to explain
that and I say wacky in the kindest way
um which is there's this theory that
basically down you you need in order to
kind of harness as you might say an oil
field you want to dredge out Free Will
from under like a you know there's veins
of Free Will in the universe and we're
Consciousness and we're the brain and
we're Evolution to tap into every one of
its possible resources it would at some
point
I mean if you think about it like
this I find it absolutely remarkable and
it kind of underappreciated fact that
every single time we discover something
fancy about the world so when we
discovered uh electricity you know a
couple hundred years ago when we
discovered uh Steam and thermodynamics
when we discovered Quantum Quantum stuff
uh when we discovered deep learning
we then look in the brain and it turns
out the brain is already doing it
and that's not just because we're
treating it metaphorically like there
are thermodynamics the brain is a closed
well not closed but it's a thermodynamic
system heat matters temperature matters
a huge amount for enzyme kinetics right
so the steam Theory it's there
um uh you know our brains are not like
computers but God damn they are very
similar in terms of that kind of
learning mechanism it's Exquisite but so
but so here's what you could do is you
can extrapolate further into the future
which is to say
well every single time you know like
before we understood gravity our muscles
and our brains were Computing
approximately 9.8 seconds per meter
squared of what gravity is anytime you
catch a ball you're having to compute
The Arc in the trajectory of the thing
with a very complicated kind of eye and
brain and history experience and all
this to approx if the fact that a
baseball player can catch a you know
well hit pop fly that brain is Computing
something very close to 9.86 meters per
second squared which is gravity it
understood gravity right the brain
understood air quotes gravity
um long before Newton it understood and
was using electricity long before
Benjamin Franklin I just got to jump in
that Patrick can you imagine what it
would be like for humans to play a game
of baseball
on a planet that had double the gravity
or half of the gravity and you would be
there and you would throw the ball
towards someone and all of the
uh parabolic lines that you had planned
for about where it was going to go and
your gloves down and then you take it
straight in the face or it drops half
the distance or a quarter of the
distance from where you would I just I
was imagining that as you were talking
being on a different planet and someone
throws the ball and you go I I I'm
starting again here in fact worse than
starting again I'm gonna guess that I
need to unlearn everything I've learned
deprogram whatever genetic
predisposition we have to 9.68 meters
per second squared and then I have I've
got to learn Mars gravity or Saturn
gravity or whatever it is foreign
for for very strange reasons involving
kind of a petrolineal estrangement I
have been playing golf since I was a kid
uh since I was like three I did the
whole tiger thing I mean he did it first
but I did it uh you know before it was
cool to like train a three-year-old and
I was taking lessons at three
I cannot conceive of a visceral
intellectual and emotional Joy greater
than being able to hit a golf ball on
the moon
like like I don't know which astronaut
it was the one of them did that I can
think of nothing I would enjoy more
because it is so
horrifying to do your best
and hit the perfect shot and just have
the ball just kind of go you know like
even if it's 300 yards away even if it's
a great well struck ball for our Earth
gravity it's still like it's mostly
heading down you know it's mostly you
see the defeat you can see the defeat in
a couple seconds you want a 1500 yards
yeah from the Moon to Earth
and I can only imagine though
it's and and what I mean by that is you
know what I was saying earlier about the
surprise of uh uh throughout a
conversation if you totally surprised
the brain and finish the sentence with a
new word your brain detects that because
it's like oh wait a second that's new
that's different let's learn from that
hold on pause
I would just do it once I would just hit
a golf ball on the moon once because I
believe that my joy would be
proportional to the amount of surprise
my brain would have and it would be like
holy [ __ ] you just hit a 1500 like
how did you you know because it would
still of course most of it the
unconscious Parts would think it was
still on Earth would be expecting that
slightly shitty 240 yard fade that you
usually get exactly exactly
um so I would do it just for that
surprise I can't wait for there to be
like uh space tourism so I can go do
that before I die
so
exotic Penrose
seeking the rivers of uh Free Will in
amongst the determinism the exterior
line of our brain is now no longer where
thermodynamics finishes and ends where
does it actually end up happening what
did Penrose have to say right thank you
um so so basically
in order so
the remarkable thing about that kind of
set of facts that the brain is always
doing something no matter what we
discover the brain is already already
doing it would be okay well what are we
going to discover in the future that we
determined we figure out the brain is
already doing right we're not done we're
we're not done with science we're not
done physics isn't done biology isn't
done so at some point in the future
we're going to discover some mechanism
by which the universe works and it will
almost certainly be the case that if it
was accessible to a biological system
Evolution would have would have found it
tapped into it and exploited it and so
Penrose and hamroth uh who's an
anesthesiologist in Penrose of course
the theoretical physicist
um they have this idea that down in the
like smallest of the atomic pieces so or
I guess not quite Atomic yet but there
are microtubules that are kind of the
reap let's call them like the rebar of
each individual cell they're the
structure The Matrix upon which a cell
uh forms its solidity and its shape
and that there's a tiny kind of
almost like a water slide in the middle
of each of these might have microtubules
and inside there you have the only
possible chance
that is where if you're going to have a
vein of free will if you're going to
have a vein of quantum uncertainty which
is where they believe free will come
that's the crude oil of free will to
this this Theory
um
that it's being mined effectively from
inside of these microtubules of which
there are
probably thousands of trillions in any
given human brain like I mean these are
the things there's like probably
Millions I don't know my order is a
magnitude but there's a lot of them in
in any individual neuron multiplied by
86 billion
um and that so basically this Theory
would say that
um when we discover that inside of that
tiny little space and it's a special
space according to quantum physics
um where basically it's too hot and too
messy and too noisy to do anything uh
bigger at bigger scales so it's the only
scale at which you might conceivably be
able to tap into Quantum indeterminacy
which just means whether or not a
particle is one way or the other or its
position
um so it's a It's like a I would say
it's a beautiful
Theory
um and what it does though is basically
take two unknowns and combine them right
it says we don't know about quantum
physics and we don't know about
Consciousness let's take the parts that
we don't know and overlap them and call
that a theory so if you were to find
fault with it as many have you know it's
it's basically that would be both the
the kind of pro and the con of believing
in that theory but we're not there yet
but you know when we say we're not there
yet it's simply the case that
um
we still have a lot of work to do right
like we still don't even have a Galileo
we still don't even have a newton
Patrick House ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do online where should
they go
uh Patrick house.com I suppose and I'm
I'm on Twitter somewhere but I haven't
quite figured out how to get over it how
to get over doing anything more than
retweeting
and 19 ways to look at Consciousness
will be linked in the show notes below
as well great great great yeah Book 19
ways looking at Consciousness not not in
the LA way subtitled not in the LA way
Patrick I appreciate you thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face